when you have to do it over and over
again how do you kind of get yourself in
the mood for that
I just prepare myself is it hard for you
to learn the line no it's sometimes when
I'm doing the shot I get nervous but I
always say to myself everybody makes
mistakes
I want to ask mostly but you know so
this thing set a good - singing dancing
I think acting - left project point I
thought sticking dip good job
et phone home my favorite part was when
evil when we first came dolls closet and
the next thing that only it discover
scent and you walk the little table and
stuff and then he says fish see the
shark ate the fish nice takes the place
Hawkins and almost ate one of the fish
and the disco-pop looks like I could act
like myself the whole time when that
shoot because dirty sword was like me
sometimes I cry and she does sometimes
caught and you can story about a whole
family and I love doing that movie when
you were in et or and even afterwards a
lot of what you talked about is how
crazy you were about Steven Spielberg
are you still such a good friend
yes we love each other it I go over to
his house and we we play games and we
see each other a lot and we're still
best friends
when you read the book did you believe
that someone could have those powers did
you ever think oh that's so we've no
one's gonna believe this
I didn't I thought as if a girl could
have those powers and I didn't think
that oh it's silly but um but it is neat
and it was neat to do the movie to work
with all those fires were you ever
scared my first time when I was like it
was like the first thing I had to do
with the fire I was very frightened but
then again I knew it was okay and I got
used to it
actresses talk a lot about preparing for
the part did you feel different on a day
when you're working in acting than on a
regular day well I go into that
character and I well I don't act like
myself I like the person I'm supposed to
be in the movie it's easy to act like
that person if you're a lot like them
it's fun to go up in front of that
camera and see yourself on that big
screen and say that's me even though
it's hard work sometimes it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]